You might see the value of things before you see the object itself.
I mean,
there are people,
for example,
who are blind.
They have blindsight,
they can recognize emotions on faces without knowing,
they can see,
so that's partly because their retinas are attached to their amygdala.
Your retina is attached to a lot of your body,
not just your visual cortex.
It's attached to your spinal cord.
It's attached to your nervous system at multiple levels of analysis
simultaneously,
and so you can use your eyes to detect things that you don't know you're seeing.
So then what is in some sense,
what you often detect under those circumstances is valence value.
So you're very good,
for example,
at detecting teeth and predatory eyes and the reasons for that are self evident.
Fundamentally.